when we perform calculations with a pen
and paper we often need to save
intermediate results and we may do this
with say scrap paper and in this case
the paper is acting as a form of
external memory and memory no matter the
form takes up physical space computers
contain memory we can think of it as the
scrap paper for the computer and say
when you construct an array to store
values in your program you require
memory
and at the lowest level computers read
and store all instructions as a string
of numbers but how do you store numbers
in a machine this was a very difficult
problem originally especially when you
need computers to hold their memory
after the access to power is lost this
is known as non-volatile memory the
easiest difference for a machine to
detect is simply a presence versus an
absence of something and this is how old
punch cards would work along the top we
have some data and the vertical columns
contain a series of punched holes which
represent each character
so computers really have two fingers
base - same as a light switch being ons
for one and off for zero this is the
smallest amount of information a single
difference which we call a bit but bits
are powerful for storage because the
amount of unique States grows
exponentially as we add bits together
remember one light switch is one bit and
it can store two states but two light
switches can store for unique States
and eight light switches or eight bits
can store 256 unique states and space is
measured in bits but the physical size
of a bit depends on your method of
storage so how do computer store zeros
and ones internally modern data
processing systems like these use
thousands of magnetic cores what are
magnetic cores there are tiny rings of
nickel alloy or other magnetic materials
they have replaced vacuum tubes for many
important functions in data processing
systems and it allowed computers to
store bits as clockwise versus
counterclockwise magnetization direction
because the each core could be
magnetized in two different ways
depending which direction the current
was applied
you
because a bit can be represented by any
stable device and a magnetic core is a
bi-stable device later on this was done
using thin film magnetic discs were we
can think of as each bit as a tiny
magnetic cell which can be charged to
store either a 1 or a 0 so long story
short the size of a bit has been rapidly
shrinking since the days of punch cards
a hard drive in a modern computer can be
thought of as billions of tiny magnetic
cells now you may wonder well how small
can these little magnetic cells be and
current research at IBM is pushing this
to the atomic level where they have
shown 12 iron atoms can work together as
a stable magnetic unit where they're
able to store a 1 or a 0 depending on
how they're oriented and this is
approaching a theoretical limit where we
would hold a single bit on a single atom
and interestingly IBM estimates that we
could put around 1 quadrillion bits of
information in a handheld device the
size of an iPod with atomic storage and
let's call this a SuperDrive it doesn't
even exist yet as a hypothetical example
a small handheld SuperDrive using atomic
storage would hold 1,000 terabits which
is 1,000 trillion switches
or more commonly known as 125 terabytes
in the palm of your hand or to use an
example everyone can understand 125
terabytes is the same as having a twelve
hundred and fifty kilometer long
bookshelf in the palm of your hand and
this is what the future of memory looks
like will we ever be able to store a bit
on something smaller than an atom